[موسيقى]
انها ثمنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض وهذه اخبار الساعه
نهايه الشوط الاول بين السعوديه والمكسيك
في المباراه المصريه النتيجه صفر مقابل
صفر ولاول مره بتاريخ كاس العالم الطاقه
من تحكيميا بقياده نسائيه غدا في مباراه
المانيا كوستاريكا
من البغدادي الى القرشي داعش فريسه سهله
بيد الامريكيين والتنظيم يعلن الخليفه
الجديد
من البرنامج النووي الى الاحتجاجات بوصلته
واشنطن الجديده تجاه طهران وموسكو تنتقد
من امريكا الى اوروبا توفر التحضيرات
لماسك بسبب تويتر والمطالب محاربه التضليل
والالتزام بالمعايير
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه وخبر الساعه
طبعا يبقى المباراه المصريه بين المنتخب
السعودي
المكسيكي اذا الشوط الاول الذي كان صعب
جدا انتهى قبل قليل
بالتعادل صفر مقابل صفر اذا الحارس
السعودي محمد العويس يعني قبل ان حسنا
وقويا جدا في التصدي اذا هجمات الفريق
المكسيكي وكانت همم هجمات كذلك قويه ولكن
المنتخب السعودي هدد شباك المكسيك في اكثر
من مره دون ان يفلح حتى الان في تسجيل
الهدف على العموم نتابع الاجواء مع همم
من لوسيل معنا اذا همم ليث بزاري
وسيكون معنا من الرياض بعد قليل نواف عزيز
او بالاحرى ليس سيكون معنا بعد قليل ولكن
نواف جاهز معنا الان مباشره من الرياض ااا
نواف اهلا بك معنا اذا شوط اول يعني صعب
جدا والاعصاب فيه مشدوده للغايه ما هي
انطباعات المشجعين حتى الان
اكثر من 40 دقيقه كانت صعبه كثيرا على
الاف الجماهير
المشجعين المنتخب السعودي هنا في منطقه
فان فيستيفال التي خصصتها الهيئه العامه
للترفيه همم ضمنها فعاليات موسم الرياض
والتي حولت حولت هيئه الترفيه ملعب جامعه
الملك سعود كما تشاهد صهيب الى منصه
مشاهده كبيره ربما كانت همم تصفيق
الجماهير خلال الشوط الاول
لحارس المنتخب السعودي محمد العويس الذي
استطاع التصدي للضربات او تسديدات قويه
وربما ايضا هجمات المنتخب المكسيكي على
المرمى السعودي هي ايضا كانت تثير
الجماهير هنا حقيقه ترقب حماس وايضا قلق
خاصه بعد انتهاء الشوط الاول
بالتعادل صفر صفر
لا تزال حقيقه الجماهير تنتظر هنا في هذا
الملعب الالاف تواجدوا
لمؤازره المنتخب في هذه الاجواء التي تنقل
المشجعين هنا الى اجواء ملعب لوسيل في قطر
بشاشه كبيره وايضا بتشجيع حماسي حقيقه لا
نزال في الانتظار وايضا الجماهير تتواجد
ايضا لاخر استراحه قصيره وانتقاط الانفاس
بين الشوطين للمتابعه والترقب لهذا الفوز
وحقيقه ربما يكون دعم همم من وزاره
الرياضه السعوديه وزير الرياضه الذي
يتواجد ايضا يثير الحماس لدى اللاعبين
وعلى الرغم من ذلك فان الاداء وفقا لما
همم لتعبيرات الجماهير المتواجده هنا اداء
كبير لدى همم المنتخب السعودي معز ايضا به
الاداء امام منتخب بولندا وايضا الفوز
الكبير على الارجنتين والذي كان الاحتفال
في ايضا كبيرا
وبالتاكيد عند فوز المنتخب السعودي سيتحول
هذا الملعب او هذا المكان منطقه فان
فيستيفال التي تشاهدونها الان الى منصه
احتفالات كبرى تستمر الى نهايه هذا اليوم
وفي الايام القادمه بتاهل السعوديه الى
دور السته عشر كما نتمنى جميله جدا عندك
في الرياض
وترقب لانطلاق الشوط الثاني اذا السعوديون
وكل العرب يتابعون بشرف وين ينتظرون هذه
المباراه نذهب الى لوسين همم واكبر
استعدادات كاس العالم في هذه الدوره في
قطر اليوم المدرجات تكتسي باللون الاخضر
والابيض مع هذه المباراه المصريه بين
السعوديه المكسيك لحسم التاهل الى الدور
ثمن النهائي ليث بزاري انقل لنا الاجواء
من عندك
ليث معي تسمعني في البيت السعودي وليس في
في وليس في ملعب لوسيل على كل حال نعم
80,000 شخص همم صاله او ملعب للسائل ولكن
هنا اتوقع الاعداء الخارج البيت السعودي
او خارج البيت السعودي تفوق ذلك فالكتير
منهم اذا اخذنا الكاميرا وتتحدث سويا او
نحن نرصد ما يحدث هنا كثير من الاشخاص
الذين
لم
سعه لاشخاص اخرون لان يدخلوا الى هذا
المكان الى البيت السعودي
همم يعني فضل الانتظام البيت السعودي
البوابه مره اخرى
ليس لعلي اطلب منك الا تتحرك كثيرا لانه
الظاهر انه عندما يتحرك الزميل المصور
الارسال ليتقطع معنا اذا يمكن ان تكون
ثابتا في نقطه ربما يكون الارسال افضل
اتفضل اليك
نعم نعم وهذا ما يحصل يعني صهيب المكان
امتلا بالمشجعين ولا يمكن لشخص اي شخص ان
يدخل الى هذه المنطقه همم منذ اقل من نصف
ساعه حتى بعد بدايه المباراه والجميع طبعا
على الكورنيش هنا في قطر في الدوحه همم
ينتظر ويشاهد ومنهم من يستمع الى الهتافات
والصفيق احيانا اذا كان هناك هدف ام لا
واذا كان هناك طبعا صار عندنا خبره يا
صهيب اذا كان الهتافات اذا كانت الهتافات
والفرحه اكثر من 30 ثانيه
تكون هناك تهديد ولكن كان هناك يعني هجمات
قويه جدا يعني في الشوط الاول
والحقيقه هناك اشادات عديده باداء همم
الحارس السعودي محمد العويس لتصديه للكثير
من الهجمات الدفاع السعودي كان قويا وكذلك
هدد شباك الحارس المكسيكي كذلك في هذا
الشوط الاول
كيف هي تعليقات والان في هذه اللحظات يبدا
الشوط الثاني همم ليث همم هل رفضت اي
تعليقات فيما يتعلق باداء المنتخب السعودي
حتى الان في الشوط الاول
الجميع معجب باداء المنتخب السعودي الجميع
هنا كان يعني النقاش همم بعد نهايه الشوط
الاول كان الم تشاهد كانوا يتحدثون لبعضهم
البعض الم تشاهد كيف كانت الحرفيه في اداء
المنتخب السعودي في هذه المباراه وهم
يسيطرون على
ليث
طيب ليس فقدنا الاتصال معك في الدوحه نعود
الى الرياض في عجاله لنرصد هذه اللحظات
الاولى لانطلاق الشوط الثاني من المباراه
المصريه بين السعوديه والمكسيك نواف عزيز
اتفضل
نعم صهيب بدات
الانماع في امام الشاشه العملاقه في
فانتستيفال وفي ملعب جامعه الملك سعود
الذي حولته هيئه الترفيه الى منصه مشاهده
كبرى سنستطلع الان بعض اراء بعض الجماهير
على الرغم من التركيز مع المباراه ولكن
محاوله سعوديه قويه
منتخبنا الوطني نبغى نحافظ على ثلاث نقاط
ناخذ الهدف ان شاء الله لكن اليوم احنا
الان على الهواء
المكسيك تتقدم واحد لكن ان شاء الله نقدر
نعدل ان شاء الله
ثلاث نقاط ونتاهل الدور الثاني باذن الله
للاسف صهيب المكسيك يسجل الهدف الاول في
شباك المنتخب السعودي يبدوا ان المشهد هنا
يتغير والاحباط يبدو على الجماهير
السعوديه
والمنتخب السعودي امام الارجنتين كان
انقلب المعادله في الشوط الثاني رغم انه
كان سجل عليه هدف نتمنى الا الا يحبط من
هذا الهدف الان الذي تم تسجيله من قبل
المنتخب المكسيك
نعم بالتاكيد صهيب خاصه مع المؤازره
الحكوميه للمنتخب السعودي وكما اشاهد الان
يبدو ان هناك
صافره ولكن لا تزال المباراه مستمره همم
المكسيك سجل الهدف الاول على المنتخب
السعودي بالتاكيد ربما الدعم للاعبين في
المنتخب السعودي الدعم من القياده ولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان الذي التقى
بلاعبي المنتخب قبل التوجه الى قطر واكد
لهم ان المطلوب منهم هو الاستمتاع باللاعب
فقط ليس مطلوب منهم شيء ربما كانت هذه
دفعه كبيره للفوز على الارجنتين وايضا
تقديم اداء جيد امام بولندا وايضا امام
المكسيك اعتقد صهيب انه حتى في حال
الخساره امام المكسيك الجماهير السعوديه
الوسط الرياضي همم هناك رضا عن ما قدمه
المنتخب السعودي ويقدمه
منتخب في كاس العالم وكما ذكر مدرب
المنتخب السعودي بان المنتخب يكتب تاريخا
جديدا بالاداء خلال همم
تعاني من غياب لاعبين ماليزيين بسبب
الاصابه والايقاف كذلك الان هناك على ما
يبدو رميه حره
ضيعه
يعني نحن نتابع اذا معك رده من خلال رده
فعل
نعم اذا ااه ركله حره اذا للمنتخب السعودي
[موسيقى]
همم لا اعلم اذا كانت هناك اي اخبار
متوفره كذلك على همم
السعوديه همم نواف في هذه المباراه
مركز همم
اللاعبين من المنتخب في المباراه مع
الارجنتين الشهراني وايضا كابتن المنتخب
ربما كان له تاثير ولكن هذا التاثير ربما
لم يؤثر كثيرا على الاداء امام بولندا
ايضا المكسيك منتخب قوي ولا زال المنتخب
السعودي يقدم اداء رائع امام المنتخب
المكسيكي المباراه همم يعني لا تزال يعني
في بدايه الشوط الثاني الجماهير تترقب
الصمت يعني يعم هذا المكان الكبير الالاف
ربما يتواجدون في هذا المكان ولكن فعليا
لا يزال رقم مستمر على الرغم من ان
المنتخب همم قام باداء مرتفع في الشوط
الاول الدفاع كان جيد اضافه الى الحارس
محمد العويس الذي همم قدم همم
محمد العويسي نعم ولكن رغم ذلك نحن همم
نريد الفوز للمنتخب السعودي اذا بانتظار
اذا نهايه المباراه
سنبقى على تواصل طباعا مع كان نواف انت
اذا في فان فستيفال في جامعه الملك سعود
في الرياض شكرا جزيلا لك حتى الان وشكرا ل
ليث ذلك كان معنا من الدوحه وفي مونديال
قطر احداث عديده لكن واحدا تاريخي مباريات
كاس العالم للرجال بقيادتي طاقه من تحكي
مين نسائيه خالص لاول مره في تاريخ كره
القدم اذا تصبح الفرنسيه ستيفاني فيربار
اول حكم تقود مباراه للرجال في نهائيات
كاس العالم لكره القدم الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم فيفا اعلن انه تم تعيين نيفر
بار لقياده مباراه المانيا وكوستاريكا
المقرره الخميس القادم وادرجه الفرنسيه
ستيفاني واروانديه سليمه موجانكا
جانب اليابانيه يوشيمي ياما شيتا ضمن
قائمه ست وثلاثين حكما اخترتهم الفيفا
لمونديال قطر بالاضافه الى الحكام
المساعدات وهن البرازيليه نويزا باك
والمكسيكيه كارين دياز مديانا والامريكيه
كاترين نسبيت بعد ان اثبتنا انفسهن في
لعبه الرجال
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اوكرانيا تستحضر
اسلحه من الحقبه السوفياتيه في حرب القرن
الحادي والعشرين القصه بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد من البغدادي الى القرشي
اصبح تنظيم داعش فريسه سهله بيد
الامريكيين المتحدث باسم تنظيم داعش يقر
في كلمه صوتيه بمقتل زعيم ابو حسن القرشي
الذي تم اختياره زعيما للتنظيم في العاشر
من مارس الماضي واختيار ابو الحسن الحسين
القرشي خلف اللحم وذكر مسؤولون غربيون
حينها انه كان مساعدا لابي بكر البغدادي
وكان مرافقا له ومستشارا كذلك في شؤون
الدينيه كما اضل لفتره طويله رئيس لمجلس
شورى داعش حسب بيان القياده المركزيه
[موسيقى]
والى الازمه الاوكرانيه وتداعيتها اصيب
موظفا بانفجار رساله المفخخه في السفاره
الاوكرانيه في العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد
وافرضت شرطه فوق على محيط السفاره معلنه
على فتح تحقيق بالحادثه وفي اول تعليقنا
على الانفجار طالبه وزير الخارج
بزياده اجراء حمايه المباني
[موسيقى]
وفي اخر التطورات المدنيه في اوكرانيا لا
تزال المعارك المحتدمه في شرقي البلاد
تقدم الروسي ومطالب اوكرانيا وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت عن السيطره على قرى بالجرو
اوفكا وبرجي ترافنيه في دمياط بالكامل
مشيره الى انه تم قصف 79 وحده المدفعيه من
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في مواقع اطلاق
النار ومناطق تمركز الافراد والمعدات
العسكريه في 275 مقاطعه في المقابله طالبه
وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيبا بتزويد بلاده
بدبابات الغربيه في اسرع وقت ممكن قال
خلال اجتماعه مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان بلاده تبحث مع المانيا سبل تزويدها
بمنظومه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو بلانكين
قال ان الرئيس الروسي يستهدف الشعب
الاوكراني بوحشيه استمر
في ساحه المعركه
على السكان المدنيين في اوكرانيا على مدى
الاسابيع العديده الماضيه قصفت روسيا اكثر
من ثلث نظام الطاقه الاوكراني مما ادى الى
اغراق الملايين في البرد والظلام مع
انخفاض درجات الحراره
التدفئه والمياه والكهرباء للاطفال وكبار
السن والمرضى هذه هي اهداف الرئيس بوتن
الجديده انه يضربهم بقوه ان هذه معامله
وحشيه لشعب اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
هذا وتعاد نيته بمساعده مولدوفا جورجيا
والبوسنه والهرسك في مواجهه الضغوط
الممارسه عليها من قبل روسيا فالدرس
المستفاد من ملف اوكرانيا هو دعم هذه هي
الدول هكذا صرح الامين العام للحلف نستمع
الى سكتمبر
الذي يمكننا تقديمه الى هذه البلدان
المختلفه ولكن تحت تاثير الضغط الروسي
بطرق مختلفه فان دعمهم الان افضل بكثير من
ما كان عليه عندما راينا التطورات تسير في
الاتجاه الخاطئ تماما اينما في وقت سابق
من هذا العام
وامام اوكرانيا الان مهمه صعبه وهي اقناعه
المانيا المتردده بتوفير انظمه الدفاع
الجوي باستريوت كاسلنديا وهذا ما يعمل
عليه وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيس
اذا كانت المانيا مستعده لتزويد بولندا
بانظمه باتريوت ولم يكن لدى بولندا ما
يمنع تسليما هذه الانظمه الى اوكرانيا
فاعتقد ان الحل بالنسبه للحكومه الالمانيه
واضح نحن على استعداد لقبولهم نحن على
استعداد لتشغيل هذه الانظمه باكثر الطرق
امانا وفعاليه وكفاءه ومره اخرى اود ان
اكرر ان هذا سلاح دفاع بحث
وعلى الرغم من التوتر
اجتماع بين رئيس المخابرات الخارجيه
الروسيه سردينار هو مدير وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه
في وقت سابقا هذا الشهر واوضحت العود
القائم بالاعمال بالسفاره الامريكيه في
موسكو ان الاجتماع بحث القضايا بين
البلدين ولم يناقش تسويه النزاع في
اوكرانيا وفي تصريحات شديده اللهجه باسمه
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ماريه زخرفه
واشنطن ايضا محاوله التلاعب بمعاهده ستارت
الجديده للحد من الاسلحه النوويه لصالحها
مؤكده في الوقت عينه ان بلادها ملتزمه
بالمعاهده رغم ذلك
[موسيقى]
اعلنت بريطانيا فرضا عقوبات على 22 مسؤولا
اشرف على عمليات تعبئه العسكريه الجزئيه
في روسيا فضلا عن نائب رئيس الوزراء
الروسي و 10 حكام مناطق وقل وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني ان العقوبات تستهدف كل الذين
تسببوا في ارسال الى في الشباب الروس الى
خطوط المواجهه في الحرب الاكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لا طالما تطورت اسلحه الحروب مع تطور
الزمن لكن اوكرانيا تخوض حرب القرن الحادي
والعشرين باسلحه من الحقبه السوفيتيه كيف
ولماذا القصه الكامله في التقرير الثالث
رغم الدعم العسكريه
لاوكرانيا باخر ما توصلت اليه التكنولوجيا
العسكريه الغربيه الا ان البلاد التي تخوض
حربا معريه منذ اواخر فبراير الماضي
الروسيه المتفوقه على سلاح قديم وقديم جدا
ولا الدقه سلاح يعود الى الحكمه
السوفياتيه يوم كانت اوكرانيا جزءا من
الاتحاد السوفيتي وهنا يبرز تساؤل مهم كيف
يمكن الانتصار في حروب المستقبل باعتماد
على معدات من القرن العشرين ولماذا
تلجاكيف لسلاحا متهالك الاجابه ببساطه ان
غالبيه تترسانه اوكرانيا العسكريه يترسانه
روسيه او سوفيه»
والتي صنعت في الستينات القرن الماضي
بمدينه خاركيز بالاضافه الى صاروخ كروز كي
اتش 35
اضافه بالطبع الى السلاح الخفيف وخصوصا
الكلاشنكوف وهو سلاح قديم النسبي ومتوسطا
ومدرعات سوفياتيه قديمه بطيئه وتستهلك
وقودا بشكل كبير
والقطارات المتهلكه والتي تعود بدورها الى
حكمه المعسكر الشرقي وحلف وارسو الذي سقط
من خلال الاتحاد السوفيتي وتفتته
من الحكمه السوفياتيه القديمه الى الغربيه
الحديثه لكن اوكرانيا وعلى ضوء امدادها
باسلحه غربيه حديثه بينها مدافعها
ومنظومه صواريخ هيمارس اضافه الى منظومات
صواريخ المانيه متقدمه تثبت فعاليه كبيره
في ساحه القتال مدعومه بصور واحداثيات
تقدمها الاقمار الصناعيه
[موسيقى]
في تونس ازمه اقتصاديه خانقه وخلاف حول
اصلاح المؤسسات العامه ينظر بتاجج التوتر
الاجتماعي جوهر الخلاف بين الحكومه
والاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل بشان حزمه
من الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه يطالب بها
الممولون الدوليون اتحاد الشغل يعارض بعض
الاصلاحات التي تشمل رفع الدعم وخفضه كتله
الاجور وحوكمه المؤسسات العموميه اما
الحكومه فتؤكد انها لن ترفع الدعم وانما
ستوجهه الى مستحقيه وانها لن تبيع المؤسسه
العامه بل ستعيد هيكلتها لانقاذها من
الازمه الماليه الامين العام الاتحاد
الشغل نور الدين الطبوبي انتقد بشده من
جانبه الحكومه في التفاوض على اصلاح
المؤسسات العموميه قائلا انها تتحايل
لبيعها وتعيش البلاد ازمه الماليه قد
تسببت في ارتفاع نسبه التضخم الى تسعه
فاصل اثنين بالمئه في سبتمبر وفي نقص
المواد
معنى من تونس البرلمانيه التونسيه السابقه
عبد العزيز القطي يوسف عبد العزيز اهلا بك
بدايه مبروك لتونس الفوز على فرنسا وهذا
الخروج المشرف من كاس العالم
ثانيا اسالك عن هذه حزمه الاصلاحات
الاقتصاديه التي يعرضها الاتحاد التونسي
للشغل ما رايك فيها
شكرا مساء النور
بالنسبه لما يقعوا في تونس او لتصريحات
الاتحاد عام تونسي الشغل لربما التصريحات
منتظره باتبار انها الاتحاد العام التونسي
الشغل يطلب منذ مده الجلوس على طاوله
الحوار
اعطاه بعض التوضيحات حول ما يحدث بين
الحكومه وهمم البنك الدولي ولكن كل هذا
يتم فيه صمت رهيب من قبل الحكومه وعدم
توضيح لكل همم الاتفاقات التي تمت خاصه
وان البنك الدولي قد وافق على 1.9 مليون
دولار لتونس لمده اربع سنوات ولكن همم ما
يقوم باتحاد اليوم هو الدور الطبيعي لهذه
المنظمه العريقه سواء ان همم منظورها او
كذلك كصوت للشعب التونسي باعتبار ان اليوم
عدم الوضوح الذي همم يتسم به المشهد خاصه
على مستوى المالي
اقتصادي عدم الاقرار بان هناك اصلاحات يجب
ان تقوم بها الحكومه من اجل ان يتم اا
الموافقه على ال ال القرض من قبل الصندوق
النقد الدولي كل هذا يجعل الاتحاد اليوم
يشك في نوايا الحكومه ويقوم بدوره الطبيعي
الا وهو الضغط وقد قام السيد نور الدين
تبوبي باعطاء مهله تقريبا لمده اسبوع الى
الاسبوع المقبل همم في
سيتم القاء خطاب في ذلك وبعض لربما ال-
ال- القرارات لتصعيد وذلك حتى يطلب من
الحكومه ان تجلس معه معه
الحوار بيكون جديديه
والحديث حول الملفات الكبرى رغم هذا
التلويح بالتصعيد ورغم المعارضه من قبل
الاتحاد التونسي الشغل هل ترى ان الحكومه
التونسيه ماضيه في تفعيل هذه الاصلاحات
الاقتصاديه
نعم هي ما فيها لربما وهناك العديد من
البوادر التي تؤكد بانه قد بدات فعلا
مساله الترفيه في الاسعار على خاصه
بالنسبه
للمواد الطاقيه
الارتفاع الموجود في الاسعار الاخرى دون
المواد الاخرى الاساسيه دون تدخل الدوله
الحديث في بعض الغرف حول خوصصه بعض
المؤسسات العموميه مساله تصريح العمل
الموظفين والتقليس من كتله الاجور كل هذا
حديث نسمعه هو لكن ليست هناك جهات رسميه
لتاكيده ولكن هناك بوادر وهذا ما يخشيها
الاتحاد العام التونسي شغل وما لا ربما
تريد ان تفعله الحكومه ولكنها ليست لها لا
الجراه ولا شفافيه الكافيه من اجل ان تقدم
برنامج الاصلاحيا واضحا يكون فيه الحوار
ويكون فيه التنسيق مع الاطراف الاجتماعيه
خاصه الاتحاد يا عمتو سوشي شغل واتحاد
الاعراف وهذا ما يجعل هذه الضبابيه ويجعل
للاتحاد لربما ياخذ هذا الموقف اليوم
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من تونس البرلماني
التونسي السابق عبد العزيز القطري
[موسيقى]
ملف ايران النووي وان غابه عن المفاوضات
العلانيه لا يغيب عن الكواليس السياسيه
واشنطن عوده الاحتجاجات الى شارع الايراني
صدت جمله اهتمامها الداخليه الايرانيه على
حساب البرنامج النووي المثير للقلق هذا
تحول تنبهت له موسكو صرح المسؤول بوزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه فلاديمير ان واشنطن
والغرب بمن فيهما المبعوث الامريكي الخاص
لايران روبرت مولي تفضلوا مؤخرا الحديث
اكثر عن الاحتجاجات وحقوق الانسان في
ايران بينما يحاولون ان يبدو هذهين
ومبهمين قدر الامكان فيما يتعلق بخطه
العمل الشامله والمشتركه بشان البرنامج
النووي الايراني على حد قوي
اما بملف الاحتجاجات في ايران النظام
الايراني كعادته الى اسلوب له سوى الترهيب
والترويع والهدف اثبات قبضته الانبياء
منظمه العفو الدوليه كشفت عن اعتزام
السلطات الايرانيه فرض عقوبات الاعدام على
ما لا يقل عن 21 شخصا اليوم يواجه احدى
عشر اخرون بينهم زوجا المحاكمه امام محكمه
في مدينه كراج بمحافظه
البرزه بحسب منظمه العفو الدوليه فان
القضاء ينوي البته بقرار الحكم بالاعدام
بحق المحتاجين بتهمه الافساد في الارض
انتهمه ذاتها التي يوزعها النظام على
مناوعيه طالت على الاقل سته اشخاص بعد
الحكم عليهم بالاعدام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حصل موقع ايران انترناشونال على نشره سريه
اعدتها وكاله انباء فارتس الايرانيه
الرسميه للقائد العام للحرس الثوري
الايراني حسين سلامي نقل فيها عن المرشد
علي خامنئي قوله ان الاحتجاجات لن تنتهي
قريبا وتم الكشف عن هذه النشره السريه
نتيجه اختراق مجموعه الهاكرز بلاك ريورد
لوكاله انباء ايفرس التابعه للحرس الثوري
وجاء في النص السري ان الجهاز المخابرات
الروسيه عن التنصت على اجهزه المخابرات
الغربيه قال ان الشعب الايراني في حاله
ثوره
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه من امريكا الى
اوروبا تواتر التحذيرات لماسك بسبب تويتر
والمطالب محاربه التضليل والالتزام
بالمعايير
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اختتمت المناورات
المشتركه الاسرائيليه الامريكيه والتي
حاكت سيناريوهات المختلفه في التعامل مع
التهديدات الناشئه في المنطقه وفي اطار
المناورات اجرت هيئه الاستخبارات العسكريه
تدريبا واسع النطاق معركه في مواجهه دول
في دائره التهديد الثالثه واختبرت قدرات
جمع المعلومات الاستخباراتيه تحليلها
وبالوره الاهداف وتمكن وصول المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه الى القوات العمليه
وتشكل هذه المناورات جزء اساسيه من
التعاون الاستراتيجي المتزايد بين الجيشين
في مواجهه التحديات المشتركه في الشرق
الاوسطها على راسها ايران
[موسيقى]
الى ازمه تويتر الان حيث شددت وزيره
الخارجيه الامريكيه على ضروره التزام
تويتر بالضوابط والمعايير المحدده للمحتوى
جاء ذلك في تعليقا على قرار تويتر بالغاء
تتبع الاخبار المظلله عن فيروس كورونا
وتنبيهات بشانها حيث يرى مراقبون ان
القرار قد يتسبب في انتشار الوباء وزياده
عدد المرضى به
[موسيقى]
التحذيرات لماسك تتوثر اذا من البيت
الابيض والخزانه الى اوروبا كذلك حيث حذر
الاتحاد الاوروبي مالك شركه تويتر لهم
ماسك من الاتجاه اتجاه المنصه لاهمال
المعلومات الكاذبه وابلغ تيري بريتون
المفوض الاوروبي للسوق الداخليه مالك شركه
تويتر الى الماسك بيض ضروره اتخاذ اجراءات
للضمان الشفافيه وحريه التعبير والتعامل
مع الاخبار الكاذبه وحملات التظليل
تويتر المنصه التي باتت تتخبط في العديد
من العواصف منذ استحواذ الملياردير
الامريكيه ايرون ماسك عليها اكتوبر الماضي
والجديد محللون يتوقعون انه بحلول السابع
عشر من يناير العام المقبل ان يصبح فيه
الى الماسك المؤثر رقم واحد على تويتر في
حال بقي حسابه
المتابعين بنفس الوتيره
فعليا حساب ماسكه على تويتر له 120 مليون
متابع ما يجعله بالفعل ثاني اكبر الحسابات
متابعه على تويتر بعد حساب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق باراك اوباما الذي يتابعه
130 مليون شخص وفي عقاب الزياده الفلكيه
لعدد متابعيه منذ شرائه منصه تويتر يقول
خبراء الاحصاء بموقع السوشل بلاي ده الذي
يقوم بتحليل البيانات من الصف التواصل
الاجتماعي ان موافق سيصل حتما الى الموت
المرتبه الاولى وسوف تكون تلك لحظه غير
مسبوقه ولكن في حال اصبح ماسك المدير
التنفيذي لتويتر ومؤثره الابرز في الوقت
ذاته هذا يعني ذلك المعلق المختص في شؤون
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
قال ان ماسك يمتلك شخصيه مشاكسه
واستفزازيه للغايه وبالنسبه للعلامات
التجاريه ربما ينظر اليها على انه خطير
اما كيف
المستشار في مجال التقنيه الناشئه فاكدت
ان دمج شخصيه المدير التنفيذي مع شخصيه
المنصه يعرض الحياديه او التعدديه للخطر
مؤشرات عده تشير الى الخطر الذي يخيم على
المنصه مسؤول كبير سابق فتوى اعتبر ان
اسلوب الاداره الديكتاتوريه التي يتبعها
ماسك يدفع الشركه الى اخطاء تجاريه غير
مقصوده المسؤول وضافه ان طرح شركه وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعيه الفاشله لميزه التحقق
المدفوعه هو مثال على كارثه مرت وسط
الفوضى التي جلبها الى الماسك الى تويتر
عناوين هنا وهناك في الصحافه الامريكيه
تنتقل الى الماسك مالك شركه تويتر الجديد
لما اجراه من تغييرات اعتبرها البعض صادمه
رئيس قسم الثقه والامان الذي استقال من
منصبه بعد استلام ماسك وصفها بغير
المتناسقه وقد تؤدي لكوارث وحسب راس الذي
وصف اسلوب اداره ماسك للشركه
بالديكتاتوريه حاول هو وزملائه فنيه الملك
الجديد عن تنفيذ فكرته بطرح نظام الاشتراك
الشهري بالعلامه الزرقاء لكن مخاطر
كبيره وربما مصيريه رئيس تحرير قسم
التكنولوجيا في الجارديان البريطانيه
دانيلو حذر من تحول المنصه الاشهر في
العالم من شركه مربحه الى اخرى مفلسه
وخصوصا على خلفيه انسحاب عدد وزن من
المعلنين او تعليق اعلاناتهم
اضافه بالطبع الى الازمه مع ابل التي الى
الان لم يصدر اي رد منها وحسب موقع ميديا
ماتز قامت 50 من اكبر مئات شركه معلنه في
تويتر بوقف التعامل مع المنصه خسائر جديده
لتويتر بنحو مليارين دولار صرفتها هذه
المؤسسات عامه 20 20
لكن الى مصر
التيار عززت هذا التوجهات تغريده له تعهد
فيها بنشر تفاصيل عن قمع حريه التعبير
التي كانت تقوم بها الاداره السابقه
لتويتر الاكيد انه منذ دخول الى المسجد
الى تويتر دخلت المنصه الاجتماعيه الاكثر
انتشارا حول العالم في نفق ازمات اصبحت
تهدد وجودها انسنا الناس العربيه
[موسيقى]
بعد عقود من المحاولات الفاشله انجاز طبيه
كشف عن عقار واعد لعلاج مرض الزهايمر
بحيثون اجرا وتجارب سرريه على العقار
الجديد المسمى لكني ماب واصفين الموافقه
على هذا الدواء الذي يبطئ من تطور مرض
الزهايمر بانه خطوه تاريخيه حيث اظهر
الدواء قدرته على الحد من تراجع المهارات
العقليه العامه لمرضى الزهايمر بنسبه 27%
على مدار 18 شهرا وهي نتيجه متواضعه
ولكنها مهمه اوافقه صحيفه الجاردن
البريطانيا من جانبه قال مدير ابحاث في
كليه لندن الجامعيه بريدي الصبر ان هذا هو
الدواء الاول الذي يوفر خيارا علاجيا
حقيقيا لمرضى الزهايمر
[موسيقى]
اقترحت المفوضيه الاوروبيه قواعد الجديده
لتقليل النفايات التغليف من خلال زياده
المحتوى المعاد تدويره في الزجاجات
المشروبات البلاستيكيه واهداف اعاده
استخدام الاكواب والمواد المستخدمه
للتسليم عبر الانترنت
بموجبه الاقتراح سيطلب من جميع اعضاء
الاتحاد الاوروبيه 27 تقليل النفايات
التغليف للفرد بنسبه 5% بحلول عام 2030
من النفايات الصلبه حول العالم
نهايه اخبار الساعه لهذا المساء تذكيرهم
بابرز العلاويه
المكسيك تتقدم بهدفين على السعوديه ولاول
مره بتاريخ كاس العالم طاقه من تحكيميه
بقياده نسائيه غدا في مباراه المانيا
كوستاريكا
من البغدادي الى القرشي داعش فريسه سهله
بيد الامريكيين والتنظيم يعلن الخليفه
الجديد
من البرنامج النووي الى الاحتجاجات بوصله
واشنطن الجديده تجاه طهران وموسكوت تنتقد
شكرا لكم على المشاهده المزيد دائما على
العربيه دوت نت على صفحتنا على مواقع
التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
مستشفى المواساه بالخبر اول مستشفى في
القطاع الخاص يقدم خدمه استبدال مفصل
الركبه باستخدام الروبوت الجراحي من خلال
الاستفاده من خدمات الذكاء الاصطناعي رحله
علاج اقصر واسهل المواساه خبره تنبض
بالثقه
[موسيقى]
تتمتع دول الخليجي بقيمه عالميه كبيره
لليوم رخاء وتطور وضعها على خريطه الدول
الاولى
لكن المنطقه التي نعيش فيها مليئه
بالصراعات تهديدات اقليميه من دول اخرى
منظمات ارهابيه وجماعات المسلحه كيف يمكن
مواجهه هذه الاخطاء ومتابعه النمو
في اخر تواجه هذه الدول وهذه المجتمعات هل
يمكن المضيق قدما في
مسامات الثقافيه وبناء ذهنيه حاضنه
للتنميه في كل مجالاتها اهم الموضوعات
المتعلقه بشان الخليجي مع ابرز المحللين
والمختصرين
هذا البرنامج يحاول صحبه ثله من المعنيين
ارتياده هذا الطريق الصعب ان نتواه مع
ابشري الزايدي السبت الثالثه والنصف على
شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
حضور مختلف بسبب الارث الفني الذي يمتلك
ولو انا مش مبسوط ما باعملش حاجه فانا
يعني لا ادعي ولا ايه اهتم قوي بفكره على
التقليد لكن
المقاربه جزء من شغل الممثل ومن ادواته
من 2013 انا بالنسبه لي كان خلاص اللي انا
قريته كله خلص الشعب المصري الان يكتب
شيئا جديدا سمعت انه انت قلت انه انت
ندمان عن همم حاتم رشيد في عماره يعقوب
صحيح الكلام فنان المصري المعروف خالد
الصاوي في سؤال مباشره
الجمعه الخامسه والنصف على شاشه العربيه
صباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
طيب في ايه بجد وصلوا وننشر قصص النجاح
لمن لديهم الشجره
ممن يعتمدون على مواهبهم كان موسم الريال
هذا الموسم الترفيه الاكبر على مستوى على
قمه
البدايه الاهرام
[موسيقى]
العربيه من الاحد الى الخميس الثامنه على
شاشه العربيه
هنالك اربعه قذائف سقطت اليوم
من المفاوضات الروسيه
ويتم توزيعهم هل يقول او يتحدث مسؤوله
الناتو من ان هذه الحرب ستقول وتتمدد
وتتوسع هنا مدينه لفيفا التي تحفظ العدد
الاكبر من اللاجئين اي تدخل لحجز شمال
اعتراف بشبه جزيره القرم
روسيا هل من تعليق التفاوض سيكون حول وقت
اطلاق النار بمقابل نحن هنا وسط نهر
الثالول الذي يقطع
الاراضي عن الاوكرانيه من حق الموقف
العسكري هو الذي يحدد الى اين تذهب
المفاوضات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مجموعه الدكتور سليمان الحبيب الطبي يسابق
المستقبل
[موسيقى]
الاخبار اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا في هذه
اللحظات انتهت المباراه المصريه بين
السعوديه والمكسيك
بفوز منتخب المكسيك بهدفين مقابل هدف
لصالح السعوديه هدف سجله الاخضر السعودي
في الدقائق الاخيره من عمر هذه المباراه
اذا هو مشاهدينا اذا الارجنتين تصعد الى
الدور الثاني اذا في كاس العالم بعد الفوز
على بولندا بهدفين
نظيفين كذلك اليوم مشاهدينا كان منتخب
تونس قد فاز على بطل العالم على فرنسا
وكذلك غادر هو الاخر تصفيات كاس العالم
اذا المشاهدين قال مسؤول من وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه شحنه صواريخ باتريوت ربما تصل
الى اوكرانيا عن طريق دوله ثالثه لم
يسمعها واضاف المسؤول الامريكيه ان بلاده
تبحث مع الحلفاء فنيته نشر نظام الباتريوت
في اوكرانيا ما سيغير قواعد اللعبه مع
روسيا وفي وقت سابق من نوفمبر الجاري طلب
وزير والدفاع البولندي من المانيا
تسليماني اوكرانيا شحنه صواريخ جو مخصصه
في الاصل بولندا وذلك لمساعدتك كيف في
الدفاع عن نفسها في مواجهه روسيا
اكيد المتحدد باسم التحالف ضد داعش
للعربيه ان واشنطن ليست لديها اي معلومات
عن عمليه محدده ستقدمها الان مشيرا الى ان
تنظيم داعش هو تنظيم خطير وان مقتل زعيم
داعش ابو الحسن القرشي
ساهيق انشطه داعش الارهابيه في المنطقه
اذا مشاهدينا كما ذكرت في بدايه الموجز
للاسف السعوديه اذا تغادر تصفيات كاس
العالم بعد فوزها في بدايه المونديال على
المنتخب الارجنتين المباراه اليوم المصريه
كانت امام المكسيك وانتهت قبل لحظات فقط
هدفين مقابل هدف لصالح همم المكسيك المزيد
بعد قليل في الكاس على العربيه مع الزميل
عبد الله الدرويش